the queen's gambit was a book i just
loved and i didn't think anybody would
make it i was shocked that netflix was
dumb enough to do it
i firmly believe that every character
has to be in the gray area they are not
all good they are not all bad and i
think that's hugely important and i
think that
you know your good guy needs to be
complicated and your
your antagonist needs to be complicated
there are three
things that get old fast um
grief anger
and drunkenness you don't want every
scene to be a different movie
and sometimes especially
newer filmmakers there's a lot of look
ma i'm directing
and so they're just trying to come up
with the most flashy
you know it has nothing to do with
what's happening deliver an emotional
payload at the end because that's what
we really want it's not just
exhilarating
it's something that's emotional on top
of that
and so you can't you can't just say
you're supposed to feel emotional here
oh look they got together you need to
feel it
and there's a difference between an
audience understanding what they're
supposed to feel
and actually feeling it
[Music]
there's there's stuff you work on that
you think are going to turn out to be
really important and you you think it's
going to be
um just a major deal and then they're
and they turn out to be nothing you know
they're either bad
or nobody went or nobody saw them and
then there are other things you do
just because you had to and you have no
expectations for them
in the case of out of sight i wrote that
because
we had three kids all sleeping in the
same room and i needed a job
to buy a house in pasadena um
um the queen's gambit was a book i just
loved
and i didn't think anybody would make it
i was shocked that netflix was dumb
enough to do it
i had a wonderful time making it in
berlin
um i loved every second of it and i
thought okay
this is the end of that and i didn't
care i didn't i didn't know if anybody
would even care
it was chess after all what drew you to
the story in the first place
well the novel is fantastic and it reads
it's a real page turner and it's
it almost reads like a thriller in many
ways she's such a fascinating character
and you even if you don't know a wit
about chess you can't put the book down
and i for some reason when i read it
bizarrely
i thought it was cinematic even though
it was about chess it just felt like a
movie to me
and i could see it and i could see her
and
so i really became it sort of became
mine in a way because i'd always been
fascinated since my very
first script little man tate with sort
of the cost of genius
and this felt like the ultimate
expression of that theme
how does a project like this take
decades to make
well i think it's not obvious um when
the book came out in 1983
i think it was bernardo berlucci who
wanted to do it and then a series of
directors came in over the years michael
apted
tom tickver there are all sorts of
people who flirted with it over the
years
heath ledger was going to do it as his
directorial debut before he died
and so it's been around and
i think everybody faced the same battle
which is
when you reduce the novel to a
screenplay
just an hour and a half two hour movie
it really becomes
a sports movie period is she gonna win
is she not gonna win
you know oh she wins that sort of thing
and
whereas if you can you can do something
longer with it
it can be about so much more i mean
endings are very much a function of
beginnings
and too often we're in a hurry in the
beginning so that there's nothing to
surprise us at the end we cut
everything out and because of studios or
because of test screenings which are
killer on the first act of movies
because you know they ask an audience
you know was there any part of the movie
that was slow
and people raise their hand and they
will say the beginning well
yeah is there any part of a book that
was slow i mean any part of anything but
they don't say was it too slow or were
you bored where were you bored
there's a different thing so they cut
out all this stuff so you get to the end
and you can't do what lindsay is
describing which is
which is deliver an emotional payload at
the end because that's what we really
want it's not just exhilarating
it's something that's emotional on top
of that
and so you can't you can't just say
you're supposed to feel emotional here
oh look they got together you need to
feel it and there's a difference between
an audience
understanding what they're supposed to
feel and actually feeling it
storytelling yarn spinning and again
this goes back to bill goldman
it's in your gut you know how do you
tell a good story how do you how do you
hum a song on key how do you tell a good
story
it's a gut thing healing regret is
a really interesting thing and i think
shame
guilt and shame are tricky because
redemption stories are their own kind of
thing and i don't know that people
i want people people are going to be
redeemed so much as
what i'm what you're really describing
is
this notion that people are not all one
thing
especially if people if they feeling
shame it's because there's something
else
to them there's some other thing that's
happened and so
i firmly believe that every character
has to be in the gray area they are not
all good
they are not all bad and i think that's
hugely important and i think that
you know your good guy needs to be
complicated and your
your antagonist needs to be complicated
and i think about
when i was writing frank griffin and
godless i thought
you know this guy is not just evil
there's something going on here where
he's fighting with himself you know and
i think we all have that and i think
we're always trying to redefine and
decide what we're gonna show
and what we're gonna you know hide and i
think that
shame guilt all those things are a part
of that but they really are a symptom of
something else a symptom of this
of of behavior or events or things that
have happened
that are good and so so it gets you
thinking for me
i arrive at shame because i've been
thinking about all these other things
that make someone live in the in the
gray area
and the stuff that's tricky to avoid
which was which was particularly hard in
the queen's gambit is there are
three things that get old fast
um grief
anger and drunkenness of any kind
it gets old super fast watching people
grieving
for too long you're like okay enough
watching people be angry for too long
you're like okay enough and watching
people
just getting stoned or drunk or whatever
over and over and over you're like okay
i got it i get it and it's very tricky
so those things and those are where
people fall to those instead of what
you're talking about they're avoiding
things by going there
and usually the anger is fake you know
it's built off of some fake conflict or
something or they're just mad all the
time or whatever it is
so if you have real characters then
there can be real conflict
you're not just saying people are not
behaving because the script said so
so again stuff like shame guilt other
feelings
remorse regret that grows out of people
who are more complicated
so you mentioned some of the grand
masters
that you could lean on are you i guess
employed quite actively for the series
and
you stage a whole lot of chess matches
over the course of the series
how did you do this in a way that was
both interesting and true to life
um it's it's an in kind of involved
answer
because it was my biggest fear and so
during prep it was
the thing i spent the most amount of
time on was
how can you render these chess
games both cinematic and part of the
narrative in a way
that people who don't play chess
understand what they're seeing
and are able to at least feel what
they're supposed to feel in during those
matches
and we we came at it from a couple of
different
directions um first in the writing of
the script i realized i
had to see what is the least amount of
chess i can get away with
what are the fewest amount of matches in
order to tell the story and see her
evolution
there were more chess matches and every
time i would rework the script i would
lose them
and even within the matches i was very
disciplined in terms of just how many
specific games we saw her play
second i realized that you had to root
or contextualize
each of these matches or games in some
sort of emotional
context you know it had you had to
understand what the stakes are not just
about winning and losing but for her
personally
and so if she self-destructs or or if
she's playing somebody who is really
important for her to beat it's not
because of
she needs to beat them to rise up in the
chess world there's always some sort of
personal
thing at stake often beth is really
hard to read and she's not very
communicative to the people who care
about her
she seems unsure how to respond to their
interest or
just unwilling affection isn't something
she understands very well
so why do we care about her
we care about her because we know she's
trying because we know
that she doesn't want to be alone and we
know
that what she's doing is something that
she can't help but it's something that
she's she's trying to fight against she
keeps trying to as i say locate herself
in the world somewhere and find who is
her family
you know and where where does she belong
and i think we care about that because
we see her searching for that and we
don't see her
gleefully being cruel we don't see her
gleefully pushing people away we see her
clumsily doing all of that
my wife was watching the queen's gambit
with me her first time my second time
and
over and over again in reference to the
main character she said
she is so peculiar
i was wondering how would you
characterize beth harmon i think that's
perfect
anya and i would talk about her um as a
creature
you know she is someone who you
sit across the chessboard from her and
you're instantly unnerved
and so i i think that she is peculiar
she's very strange
um she doesn't speak a lot sometimes
she's very awkward in what she says a
little too direct
um and she you know just wants what she
wants
and she's almost feral you know she is
this sort of feral genius in a way
so a lot of this really has to do with
how you and
anya taylor joy the lead actress i guess
drew upon who she is as an actress her
features are huge eyes
to kind of embody this person with that
sort of strangeness huh
yes we definitely leaned into all of
that visually
and i needed somebody because so much of
it was gonna be on her face which is
which is different for me you know i
don't usually like to shoot too many
close-ups
and this was gonna live in a lot of
close-ups i needed somebody whose face
you just
couldn't stop studying who was just
fascinating and anya has an amazing
amazing face and she
it's so expressive and you can read so
much into it she can do
so much with those eyes not every
director feels comfortable
encouraging you to speak not every
director feels comfortable
not being so in control of
absolutely everything while scott's like
i picked you for a reason
what do you think about this scene and
he encourages you to be in it with him
so that you can build something together
he's always in control he always has
the vision of where it's going and if
something is wrong he will tell you it's
wrong but
it felt so beautiful to be on a set
where you really knew that you were
valued
not just as you're the actor just act
and like do what i tell you to do
essentially it was what do you think why
does this not feel right to you
okay let's unpack that which way do you
want to do it one take for you
okay great like that ability to have
a lack of ego in a role that i think
you know as a director you're directing
the ship
you can you can get a little bit drunk
on your ego sometimes i i would imagine
and
and scott just doesn't have that and he
never cracks
he's always smiling and he's always
there for you in such a
we love you you're wonderful i i've only
watched this series once but i don't
think you used
handheld until the very end
yeah um good get i would say
um so stephen and i you know
meisler is the cinematographer we talk
we kind of set rules for ourselves
you know only these lenses never
handheld or
you know or only handheld went for this
or that or whatever it is we have very
specific rules so that
so that um uh you don't want every scene
to be a different movie
and sometimes especially
newer filmmakers there's a lot of look
ma i'm directing
and so they're just trying to come up
with the most flashy
you know it has nothing to do with
what's happening it's just
so i'm a big believer mostly because it
helps me make decisions on the day
if you have these rules for yourself you
know it's only going to be this palette
these these are the colors and no other
colors are going to be let into this
show
so the costume designer and the
production designer can all work that
way it's going to be all natural light
we're going to shoot whatever your rules
are everybody has their own rules
so with this it was a very classically
shot show
i was very moved by a movie called eda a
polish film
and in ida the camera never moves ever
ever
camera does not move and so people are
moving within the frame
and there's never an adjustment it just
sits there and the only time i'd ever
seen that was
for comedy in napoleon dynamite where
they did that
so we're kind of a proscinium sort of
thing but anita
never moves until the very end when
she's back in her habit
and she's walking along and it's this
handheld shot of her
now back as a nun where she'd explored
life
as not a nun and now she's none again
it's a beautiful film i recommend
everybody see it
um i wanted a similar feeling
with this and i wanted it to be this
kind of sense of freedom
and if it were just a steadicam which we
did a ton
of it would be it would feel too much
like when she walks into the orphanage
where it's this kind of
i didn't want it to feel choreographed
and so what's
what's not just the fact that it's
handheld but she's walking and then it
kind of goes over
through the tables it's a very rough the
whole thing some people were even like
is it shaking too much
no no because it's just freedom
that's going on right here and and
you see it on her face too you see it on
her face and look at the
look at the background you can see just
how bad we're shaking
you know it's just really rough and
tumble
but after six and a half hours of hours
of being
exactly and then you let her go you let
her go for a second
in this super wide shot and then
back again because she's about to meet
these guys and then we bring in these
guys
and then it'll get very controlled again
in a moment but
so that was the reasoning behind it it
was a very much a character
story thing you do start to see
a kind of common denominator in terms of
mistakes that are made in screenplays
you do see even
professional scripts that are getting
made because if i'm going to rewrite
something and i've done it
i don't know 40 times or something say
they'll come to you three weeks before
they're shooting
they're in trouble and they need help
and they've only got
several weeks before they start to shoot
and almost always
the problem is there's no characters
there's nothing there they can't get an
actor or the actor that's there is
unhappy
nobody's written real people they've
written attitudes or they've written
somebody who's beautiful or
you know handsome and rugged and strong
but not a person
and so at the last minute they're trying
to imbue these scripts
with with characters that that's a big
problem the other problem that happens
is
tone tone is a really hard thing and i
don't think they talk about it enough
when they talk about writing creating a
consistent tone
is very difficult to do sometimes the
problem with the movie is that the tone
is all over the place one minute it's
funny and then
and it's trying to be scary and or or
it's not dramatic enough or so you don't
believe it because and if tone is
inconsistent you don't believe the thing
you're watching it does it starts to
become not real
and so that's that's another another
problem and then the other stuff falls
in under the heading of
of third act problems you know they
don't know how to end it or the third
act doesn't work and it's
more often than not because the first
act doesn't work because they haven't
established
good characters whenever i'm stuck
99 of the time it's because the people
aren't good enough
it's not because i can't make up where
to go i can't make up where to go
because the characters i've written
don't have enough to tell me
i don't know enough about them and i
always go back and i start thinking
about the people i'm writing about and
suddenly
20 ideas for scenes present themselves
you